let's say we've been hanging out in
scenario e for a bunch of days on
average we've been catching one rabbit
but gathering 280 berries we were i
guess in a in a very mood so this is
scenario e right over here but now all
of a sudden we're in the mood for more
protein so let me write down we are in
scenario
e
and we're in the mood for more protein
and so we we want to think about what
are the trade-offs if we try to catch
more rabbits so what i want to do i want
to say if i want to catch one more
rabbit
one more
one more rabbit
what am i going to have to give up so if
i catch one more rabbit so i go from one
rabbit on average to two rabbits a day
so i'm really going from scenario e to
scenario d what am i going to give up so
this is plus 1 over here well i'm going
to give up i'm going to give up 40
berries
and you can see it visually right here
if i try to get one more rabbit i can't
go into this impossible this
unattainable part right over here i have
to stay on the production possibilities
frontier sometimes sometimes abbreviated
as pp as ppf or i guess the acronym for
it i should say is ppf but if i want one
more rabbit
the production possibilities frontier
drops off and i will have to give up 40
fruit so one more rabbit means that i
have a cost so i have to give up
i have to give up on average 40
berries and the technical term for what
i've just described is the the
opportunity cost of going after one more
rabbit is giving up 40 berries so let me
write this down the opportunity cost
opportunity
cost
of
one
more rabbit one more rabbit and this is
particular to scenario e as we'll see
it's going to change depending on what
scenario we are in at least for this
example so the opportunity cost of one
more rabbit is
is 40 berries
is 40 berries assuming we are in
scenario e one more rabbit i have to
give up 40 berries and another term when
we talk about the opportunity cost of
going after after producing i i guess we
could say the opportunity cost of
producing one more rabbit here when we
talk about the opportunity cost of
producing one more unit that's sometimes
called the marginal cost so this right
over here you can also view as the
marginal cost
marginal
cost in the context of this video our
costs are in terms of the thing that i'm
giving up the opportunity that i'm
giving up in in other scenarios you'll
see sometimes the marginal cost be given
in an actual monetary units like dollars
or whatever else what was the cost of
producing that extra unit that extra
widget right over there
but let's make sure we understand
opportunity cost so that's when we're
sitting in scenario e the opportunity
cost of one more rabbit but what's the
opportunity cost sitting in let's say
we're we we're tired of eating meat
we're sitting in scenario e and we want
to become vegetarians all together so we
want to go to scenario so we want to get
we want to go to scenario f essentially
not eat any rabbits and eat as much
fruit as possible so another thing that
you could ask in scenario e is the
opportunity cost
opportunity cost of and just to make the
numbers easier i'm going to say
opportunity cost of 20 more berries 20
more berries
20 more berries is well i'm going to
give up i'm going to give up a rabbit
so over here what we're doing is we are
we're saying okay i want to increase my
berries by 20. but to do that i have to
decrease my rabbits by one so the
opportunity cost assuming we are in
scenario e the opportunity cost of 20
more berries is
one
is one
rabbit now this right over here is not a
marginal cost because i'm talking about
the cost of 20 more units not just one
if i want to write this as a marginal
cost of one more berry then i could just
say well if 20 berries is one rabbit you
could say you could essentially divide
both sides by 20. so one more berry
one more
one more berry and i'll assume for those
of you want to get technical that it's
somewhat linear right over here one more
berry if we divide both sides by 20 is
one more berry is one twentieth one
twentieth of a rabbit so if i go for one
extra berry sitting in scenario e on
average on average i'm gonna get one
twentieth less of a berry and when i
when i phrase it this way it is being
phrased it is being phrased as a
as a
marginal
marginal cost now for those of you want
to get a little technical this is a
curve right over here so it might not be
exactly this we can't just well i don't
want to get too technical for for the
sake of this one right over here this is
a safe way to think about it the
opportunity cost of 20 more berries is
one rabbit but if you assume that this
is somewhat linear right over here it's
not so curved it's somewhat of a line
between those two points then the
opportunity cost of one berry is one
twentieth of a rabbit or the marginal
cost of an extra berry is one twentieth
of a rabbit and we could do it at
different points in this curve and i
actually encourage you to do
based on the data that we have in this
table that we constructed in the last
video and maybe this curve think about
what the opportunity cost is
in the different scenarios if you're in
scenario b and if you want an extra
rabbit how much is that going to cost
you in terms of
in terms of in terms of berries or if
you want more berries if you want more
berries what's that going to cost you in
terms of rabbits